so the job of the writer is not to
supply the ideas it is to be patient
enough
to find the ideas
david and goliath is a concept we all
know an arrogant big dude
who thinks he's fighting a sword fight
and david changed the rules
but then i stumbled across this paper
that had been written by an israeli
endocrinologist
who had suggested goliath has this
really rare medical condition
which causes you to lose your eyesight
why do giants lose because they can't
see they're so big and strong and
powerful
they lose the ability to kind of
properly appreciate the world around
them
it's not just a story about david's
courage and greatness
it's a story about goliath's blindness
you can find gold in the smallest of
details if you're willing to be
patient we're going to talk about
suspense structure research humility
characters puzzles and semicolons
one of the mistakes i think writers make
is they spend a lot of time
thinking about how to start their
stories and not a lot of time thinking
about how to end them
knowing my ending makes the beginning
super easy
right it's totally clear what i have to
do and totally clear what i shouldn't do
your first goal is to be clear and
simple to write at an 8th grade level
but with ideas that are
super sophisticated all good nonfiction
writing is about
going out and finding someone else and
inhabiting their world and representing
it to readers
it is giving us a window into other
people's hearts and souls and
minds i'm malcolm gladwell
and this is my master class
you